all right jada
yes jada where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from murphysboro
tennessee originally wow
tell me about how you grew up you had
mom and dad my parents were around but
they were
my mama worked all the time so i
realized with my dad a lot and then
honestly
they always
fought a lot and
just it was just really kind of
and
it's like dysfunctional
like um i feel like my mother wasn't
i felt like my mother wasn't there like
she should have been for me being a
female
as far as like
you know keeping me i guess you could
say guarded and
knowing you know right from wrong as far
as with the men's and everything else so
like is there stuff going on
yeah a lot of stuff going on she was
never around and then like honestly
i guess them trying to keep me guarded
made me want to break
more
and rebuild more
so i ended up
doing drugs and starting drugs at like
16 17.
and really i started off with weed
basically but then the weed progressed
to the cocaine and
i've tried almost everything i guess you
could say except for
pcp sure and stuff like that but
otherwise
i guess i have addicted personality so
if i try not like it i'm gonna do it
and if i like it i'm gonna keep on doing
it
which is kind of not good but
otherwise
those drugs led to
me
prostituting basically
and nine times i think just walking down
the street you know a man might
proposition a woman and i'm the type
where
i'm not gonna turn any money down but
also i wasn't using money for the drugs
versus
being paid for six for drugs
so basically [ __ ] that got me
i
i met some characters i guess you could
say i mean like it's been a couple of
times where i've almost been in some
sticky situations where
you know um kind of being abused by a
customer or two
and
you know kind of scary but
at the end of the day i mean it's the
money really and i know this supports my
habit what's the worst thing that ever
happened to you doing the worst thing is
getting beat up
by one of my
regulars he was a regular you know he
was a regular see him all the time
really he's gonna like twice a week
and i don't know what
he had going on this time but
he ended up
basically beating me up i had a black
eye and a broken blood vessel in my eye
on mine
and that's
yeah about that yeah he almost got to
the point where he he almost he tried to
write me but he didn't
he he didn't get that far
which is like one of the scariest things
ever happened in my life honestly and i
was sober so it was a big difference
because i wasn't able to numb that away
that's how i even got down here to
california all through prostitution
meeting people and
going on trips like saying hey i want to
go that's how i got here too to
california because i came here from
jacksonville florida duvall county i was
prostituting there too
met a man who was coming here to handle
some business and i told him i wanted to
come
and he brought me and i've been here
ever since
back to your childhood was there sexual
abuse in your childhood um
as far as
i've had
i've been around older older i get today
like older
people my age but they were older so
like i had two situations where
me and one person we were basically at
their family's house and he
told me to go to the bathroom let's go
to the restroom you know
and you know let me see yours let's see
mines and then i got the touchy feely
and
which i wasn't trying to do nothing else
but he kind of
pushed it on me a little bit
and so
therefore i had to
do the performance of what i was
supposed to do what you want me to do
and
after that i haven't talked to or seen
him ever again
that's the worst thing i'm telling me
and it's scary how old are you i'm 38
years old no i was were you with that
back then i think i was like 12 13.
because he was like 15 16 because my
mother told me to stay away from him and
i didn't listen to her
and that he was
too older and two more mature
and i should have listened and i didn't
i've been to college and everything like
i literally have been all right but
i guess it's the rebellion
and being told to do right but wanting
to do wrong
that also led me down this early path of
mine which i want to change but where do
you think that comes from the desire to
do wrong to be bad
more from
more from being watched and looked at
and running like saying oh you gotta do
this right you gotta do this right so my
thing is more like well i'm gonna do it
wrong just because i want to
first you always tell me do this and do
that because it's gonna make me wanna go
seek and find what you tell me to stay
away from
and that's how that's why i started
experimenting with like i had been my
friends growing up i already been weed
smoking do whatever like i never tried
it with them at first but then when my
parents couldn't tell me oh don't smoke
no weed don't smoke weed
i was like [ __ ] it so one day after
school i went to a friend's house and
they were smoking i smoked with her and
i liked it
and ever since then
i've always been an avid weed smoker i
always smoke weed to the day i die
but i also let you other things because
like i said the weed does not always get
too high i dropped powder cocaine first
and snoring in the nose you know the
stepping stone
of your nose is not a good feeling after
the fact so
i had ex who was
31 i was 19 and he smoked those uh what
they call them the primos and the papers
and the tobacco and the cocaine
tried those you know like the smells
tasted good then i graduated say [ __ ]
just start putting the glass pipe in my
mouth
and after that
and after that
i stopped for like a couple years but
then the stopness led me to do crystal
meth
and i was watching intervention one day
and i seen the lady blow smoke and i was
like oh wow i want to do that and i
moved to a town in georgia they had
crystal meth and i met some people
and started doing crystal meth
is prostitution a way to support your
drug yes
yes it is anyway and also i have to say
i i'm like dibble and devil and sell
drugs you know to here there but just
only to
like support that habit or whatever and
then when we got to practice i'm very
particular
very particular i'm not in these 20
dollar hoes walking down the street
because they have made the game messed
up for a lot of people with the 20 hour
stuff they have but at the end of the
day i'll never never never never do it
for drugs
because i look at it like you can't tell
me what i'm worth as far as drug wise
when i get that money and go spend it on
well i want to spend now because i might
want to spend all on drugs i might want
something else to do you know
and you have a lot of men that do that
too to as women because we have actually
made it like that i think if we didn't
know our standards or lower ourself to
the point where we would lower our worth
for that person i feel like it would be
so totally totally different
i really do
honestly
but you know there goes society and what
we see around this is going to always be
brainwashing puts our minds to the point
where this is what
it is so you learn so much in the end
it's like boom
that's what it is what you expect what
have you learned about men from your
years of doing this kind of work oh men
aren't bad
all men aren't bad and honestly i look
at it like
i can't say like a job but more like
like they say if it's something that you
want you're gonna pay for it
or you're gonna go get it so at the end
of the day with me and it's the same
thing it's not nothing different i don't
think it's anything different it's just
their preference may be
you know a sexual
not initial addiction but you know like
that sexual appetite they might not be
getting enough of it at home you never
know
whatever otherwise
not all men are bad
some of them you take it like into like
you're the ones that are your regulars
that you get to know
so it's a big difference like i don't
look at them as just only a cut like
only just you know a question right now
it's a total big difference because you
know they might you know say oh it's not
about sex let me just pull up on you and
just you know go eat something or
something you know so i can't i don't
judge and that's my problem too because
i think that's one thing i have a
problem with i don't discriminate so
i give everybody the benefit of doubt so
i don't
i lower my standards too much
because i know i know that what i'm
doing is wrong
i mean i'm 38 years old i have two kids
which i'm thankful for because i really
thought i had more but
it is what it is
to do
you raised your kids
um yeah i've been there for most of for
both of them and like right now my
parents have my son and my daughter so i
have a relationship where i call every
day all day my son one thing i say he's
16 and he does not judge me he loves his
mother no matter what
literally and he's like my mom i'm gonna
turn 18 i'm gonna come with you together
for him like he does not and i put my
son through a lot of [ __ ] so i ended out
of jail he was there with me when i got
arrested for the first time i didn't
like he really could have been gone to
those people already it was like nine
months but what brought you out to
california
prostitution
honestly prostitution i was in
jacksonville florida i met this man who
had got social security from here and
florida
and he was coming it was father's day
weekend i'll never forget he was coming
that weekend to come into some business
i just searched the office and i just
met him this man was like hey i got a
friend he has a lot of money i was like
cool he's he's a trick or a pimp he was
a traitor
he was a trick what i never do is have
no pimp because can anybody sell my
[ __ ] for me but me
he don't know i'm my own pimp
i'm my own pam because can't nobody
putting the price on myself with me and
there's no way in hell that i'm gonna be
getting these men
and giving my money to the next
[ __ ] who really gonna do [ __ ]
for me no way that i can't do for myself
honestly
for i have a boyfriend now who's he used
to be
not a pimp but he called a
mac is what they call themselves and
he's telling me the difference between a
pimp and a mac
because i think they uh pimp is going to
be you know the one that might want to
have sex with all these girls i'm going
to take care of them right now that but
mac is going to make sure that his
females are at the par
you know
for their client whatever the case may
be make sure they're good not make them
feel like they're you know nothing or
abuse or whatever the case may be i'm my
mama he used to be that he was in las
vegas he took over somebody's spot for
real he said he became a mat with
nothing
with zero dollars yeah
so today you're staying on skid row
yes yes yes yes yes i'm on wall street
let's get right there where all the
heroin and the fentanyl and everything
is that you're you're in a tent
yes sir yeah
and then like i have judgments there all
the time
i mean really it's more of a means of
waste of taking care of myself like i
don't have to go ask nobody for nothing
like that's one thing i will not do and
i cannot do that i don't even feel right
asking somebody to give me 25 cents just
walking down the street like i don't i'm
not comfortable with that because i'm
used to doing it for myself regardless
or whatever so it's like
like really
just like what i want to do is really
not i mean i've been to college all that
stuff i mean like literally like this is
not what i want to do but for the moment
is what i'm doing because i mean it's
money involved and i mean like i've had
times where
like i would literally daytime like this
i've made like two three hundred dollars
i just surrendered
gamble all day i'd like to play a lot of
teams
but otherwise i would never
you know too excessive but it's good to
always have regulars always good to have
brothers it is because you know for sure
boom i know that this day of the week
that this person's coming at this time i
know exactly what's gonna happen i know
that's how long it's gonna take
but literally i'm a precise person i
just like to wham bam thank you mail
i don't get high within my clients
nothing because my thing is if you don't
know what i do you can't
limit me to what you give me and you're
working the guy i got this street hell
no that's one thing i won't do i get to
i've been there like a couple times in
the first couple times i went it wasn't
too bad but then you got too many of
those [ __ ] walking around so it's
like
they're second guessing or you're
training too and like hell no so i'd
rather just like on my side whether you
know it or not
it's a lot of
i can say like more um
mature and more
cleaner i guess you could say
men that are around in that section and
plus
not all the time it has to do with sex
like it could just be
uh to smoke with let me look at you or
something like that you know
if they want to smoke it depends on who
it is
and
what they're offering because my thing
is if you know that i get high then now
then after this you might be like oh
well now let me drop the price or you
know let me give her some smack i don't
know you shouldn't go waste on drugs
anyway which you don't know if i'm going
to rush on drugs anyway because that's
why i said i already have drugs already
and like i said that money i'm using i
have to go buy me an outfit
i like to eat
food whatever the case may be like right
now something like that we're going to
cut the street grab me some clothes i
like the vibration drugs
and today's gonna be a good day today
i'm not gonna do any
hard drugs today
and do not take it one step at a time
honestly but then it's like being around
the environment that environment is
really what gets you to because it's
like if you say you're going to do
something but then you're around the
people who do it or you're in that
section that's going to make you want to
do it yeah you're addicted to the whole
lifestyle
yeah honestly
lots of years because like i've been
like so many times you know people be
like oh daddy let's go
here let's go there we could see this
like down the street i'm like [ __ ] i
ain't got time right now
like literally
like i'm um i don't want to walk away
from the money
and that's the problem too is like
in my mind i'm thinking oh
i'm gonna walk away from the money so
you're saying like i can't make nobody
ever hear something like [ __ ] what do
you hear for you know i mean
i mean obviously that's how you think a
lot to you sometimes like if i'm
somewhere and i can't make no money i'm
like why don't you be over here because
i know me sitting here ain't no telling
who they came by my spot
well i've been sitting here want to
spend some money and i have built my i
can't say well i say build my clientele
up to the point where um
i had those rehab kids
like down here in california you know
they have the ppos where they go you
know they get paid to do rehab whatever
they come back with thousands of dollars
stuff like that i mean like i have a lot
of those kids that come spend hundreds
come hang out with jada because they
love me so much
and then like
literally like you never know who you
can meet
and i met a couple people like one man
his
his wife was ahead of the va hospital
like she's the head of staffing all that
like literally
but they're my customers
i don't know you that that's crazy
because what you see on the outside this
might
be what you get on the inside
what's your biggest regret in your life
the biggest regret would be
the biggest regret would probably be
not listening to my parents what i
should have
honestly
because i mean growing up as an
african-american child i was basically
given the opportunity
to be a successful person in the world
like they really gave me the stepping
stones like my brother was 10 years
older than me and they gave me basically
the same thing they gave him
to make it you know like here's the
little tools that you need you know let
me help you you know give you that push
but honestly i [ __ ] it up i mean and i
did it not because i had you because i
wanted to what's your brother doing
today my brother he works at nissan
which is you know a car company so he's
got a good job yeah and then he's had
his his lawnmower service he's been
doing since he was 16 and he's
46 now
he doesn't have any life on the streets
at all none whatsoever i mean like we're
telling the opposites like he
he used to and he might not even do no
more he used to drink alcohol like drink
beers and stuff but he don't even think
he does that anymore but me on and then
i'm so so so
obviously in the white house
what makes a person take that path
what do you think
i feel like depending on who that person
is
you know some people that might have
grown up grown grown up in the
atmosphere so of course it's what you're
used to so you adapt to it so that's
what you know
then you have people like me
who were like
let me try just you know like i don't
know i have addictive personalities like
something i like i'm gonna try if i like
it i'm gonna keep on doing it like i
didn't lie to you i even tried hair on a
couple times and not down here
but in florida where i can't have dog
food which is not that tart [ __ ] or
whatever
and literally like just being around
people and watching them
get i guess
i was like [ __ ] i want to try that one
day and i did ain't gonna lie i did and
then i started liking it but i was like
oh hell no that's a 20 i haven't i do
not want because now i see the aftermath
and the effects of the sickness you know
people get because i mean like i
literally get people well sometimes too
i mean it is what it is i might go buy
you a backyard if i don't want to re-up
i have a friend that i literally would
give him 1000 times and go get some
drugs
like honestly i mean i guess that's just
me being too
kind and nice and like i said i'm not
judgmental so that's a big downfall for
me honestly it is
a huge downfall
what do you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
that i
[Music]
i can't limit myself to my words on my
mama that i know that my wife is more
and i just need to put it to use
more
and really get myself together and stop
doing what the hell i'm doing because i
know i'm better than this honestly
why not
all right
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you so much for letting me i need
to get that out because i've got a lot
of stuff in i wish you the best of luck
thank you sir
you